if you want to hear the unknown truth
about where Gordon went and all that
time between sawed and sawed seven yeah
I prefer to call seven instead of saw 3d
so get used to it and stick around to
the end of this video
jigsaw the man who brought his judgment
down upon the world of the Saw franchise
had many disciples who lent him a
helping hand at some point along his
journey but the man considered to be his
greatest asset was dr. Lawrence Gordon
welcome to horror history
my name is the email version of Kevin
from home alone I actually used to get
that a lot when I was a kid - the email
part today we're covering a fan favorite
it's dr. Lawrence Gordon Gordon was
played by actor Cary Elwes who appears
in the original saw and comes back for
Sasa after a financial contract dispute
hobbled the original plans for Gordon to
appear in saw three unintended always
had to wait for a higher budget before
making his return but Elway's much like
his character continued to keep tabs on
the saw world without making an
appearance for years before his
triumphant comeback we're gonna analyze
dr. Gordon's entire life so let's take
it back to the start of his story
Lawrence Gordon graduated from Indiana
University School of Medicine on June
4th 1979 this was the first major
accomplishment he would achieve in his
impressive medical career he would
become a doctor surgeon and later
oncologist at the angel of Mercy
Hospital he married a woman named
Allison and in 1996 they gave birth to
their only daughter Diana Lawrence and
Allison did discuss having another child
after Diana but ultimately decided that
their schedules were too busy and they
barely had time to concentrate on the
daughter that they had the busy
schedules put a strain on their
relationship and dr. Gordon became cold
and emotionless toward his wife as she
became pissy and unruly towards it his
constant preoccupation with work also
caused his daughters to feel higher
towards his pager and she felt that work
got in between her and her father in
2004 dr. Gordon's relationship with his
wife was very weak and he's having an
affair with a medical student the
hospital named Carla song they would
arrange times to meet at seedy motel
rooms in the middle of the night in June
of 2003 dr. lynn denlon was working
under dr. Gordon in the oncology
department where they diagnosed a colon
cancer patient named John Kramer with an
inoperable frontal-lobe tumor
glioblastoma multiforme nine months
after that on March 24th 2004 he was
found to have speech altering brain
damage due to more cancerous growths
when dr. Gordon called John into his
office
to tell him how long he had to live John
found his demeanor to be cold and harsh
John felt that he did not cherish life
and did not appreciate the effects that
telling a man his expiration date would
have psychologically John plans to
rehabilitate the doctor using an
elaborate game that Lawrence would be
forced to partake in John would soon
become known as the jigsaw killer for
the trademark jigsaw piece that he cut
out of each of his victims in May of
2004 Gordon would learn of jigsaw for
the first time he was out late one night
saying Karla and the next day while
examining John's tumor for an audience
of Karla and the other students he's
called out for his emotionless medical
proceedings by an orderly named dizzy
Florence mock is apt for having special
bonds with the patient's before he can
get back to his demonstration he's
called into his office for another
distraction there he meets two cops
singing tap who questioned him about his
whereabouts the night before Gordon's
penlight was found at the crime scene of
one of jigsaws victims where a man had
been burned to death so the cops wanted
him to provide an alibi
not wanting to admit he had cheated on
his wife Gordon is hesitant to provide
his whereabouts and they take him down
to the station his lawyer and friend
brett's recommends that Gordon give his
alibi while he still has the chance and
in doing so they're able to clear his
name but one of the detectives David
Tapp is still suspicious they asked
Gordon to stay a bit longer to hear the
testimony of one jigsaw victim that
escaped her trap so he sticks around
hear the story of Amanda young and is
horrified by the brutality but still has
no answers as to why his pen light was
found merely knowing about jigsaw was
not enough to get Gordon to change his
ways though because five months later in
October he's up late working once again
when his daughter diana has a little
sleepwalking incident and asked to see
her dad he doesn't even look up from his
computer as his wife tells him about
what happened I imagine this is what I
look like when I'm editing a video he
does eventually go to put her to bed and
check the room with her because she
believes that there's a man
there's no such thing just a bad man how
can you go to sleep I would beg to
differ but Lawrence doesn't notice
anyone in the room and eventually gets
called away when Karla tries to contact
him using this page on his way out his
wife tries to pick a fight with them
because she's completely starved for
passion in the relationship he meets
Karla at a rundown join known as the
hotel barfly but instead of hooking up
his better judgment kicks in and he
tells her that they should stop this
could be because he actually felt bad
about his actions but I think it may
have had more to do with the fact that
Karla crossed a line by buzzing his
pager while he was at home
you deem it necessary to page me what
you knew I was at home can't do that
before leaving a call comes in which
alarms him because nobody is supposed to
know their location on the other end a
voice tells him I know what you're doing
the voice is raspy and whispered but it
doesn't sound like the voice that jigsaw
usually uses to address his victims I
think this may actually be Zeb who is
also a part of jigsaws game and had to
follow his instructions if he wanted to
survive dr. Gordon hurried home after
this not realizing that he was being
followed by a photographer named Adam
Stanton who had been hired by a still
suspicious detective Tapp to keep an eye
on him Adam would leave however before
seeing the ambush that would take place
shortly after in the parking garage dr.
Gordon woke up in a dark dilapidated
bathroom with his ankle chains to an
immovable pipe across the room Adam is
in a similar predicament but Lawrence
did not yet know who Adam was there was
another man in the center of the room
who is pretending key word pretending to
be dead and this is John [ __ ] Lawrence
turns on the light and realizes that
everything in the room is old and
rusting other than the clock which is
new he finds a tape in his pocket along
with a bullet and a key he throws his
tape to Adam for him to play it out loud
it's a voice recording by jigsaw telling
Gordon that he's getting a wake-up call
roll the tape
that they're gonna die so now you will
need a cause of death your aim in this
game jigsaw tells him that he has to
kill Adam by six and gives him two clues
the red substance on the ground is
actually laced with poison and x marks
the spot he also says that Alison and
Diana's lives are at stake as well and a
whisper at the end
follow your heart gordon notices the
heart on the toilet which leads adam to
finding the hacksaw is in there but they
aren't strong enough to cut the chains
that's when dr. gordon realizes the
purpose is to cut off their feet he
remembers about amanda and how jigsaw
was still on the loose after that they
discover a camera is watching them
behind the mirror and gordon begins to
think more creatively about how to
overcome the game by likening it to his
work it will become something you have
to understand what a perfect tension it
is that's how you fight disease this
line shows John Kramer why Lawrence is
actually a perfect candidate to win the
game and become his successor Gordon
doesn't have the engineering know-how
that Kramer does but he shows an ability
to use the concepts in what he does no
medicine in order to accomplish whatever
he puts his mind to but Gordon would
have to be pushed to his limit before
having the opportunity to prove his
worth while reflecting on the last words
he said to his daughter he shows Adam a
picture of her from his wallet and Adam
finds a clue that leads him to ask for
it and to try turning out the lights
glow-in-the-dark paint
eliminates the X and Gordon smashes
through to find a box containing a phone
and two cigarettes gordon is suspicious
about how adam knew to turn off the
lights and adam eventually reveals that
he was hiding a note found in the wallet
on the back of a picture of Alison and
Diana being held captive upon seeing
this photo gordon emotionally breaks
down but hold on is gordon really losing
his cool right here i think maybe not
see gordon already knew that his family
was in danger plus he's never
demonstrated anything other than being
cool collected and calculating when
faced with any kind of adversity whether
it be his unstable wife being accused of
committing a crime or finding himself in
a life-or-death stakes escaper then take
his next move into account he devises a
plan where he pretends to kill Adam by
whispering he for him to play dead while
the lights are off and making it look
like he tossed the cigarette dipped in
poison rather than the clean one with
this plan in mind it makes sense that
dr. Gordon would want to sell the
performance by pretending to have a
meltdown over this photo making it look
like there was a valid reason that he
now decided to kill at this level of
thoroughness
another great example of why Lawrence
possesses the material needed to be
jigsaw
unfortunately for dr. Gordon Adams
acting is not quite as OnPoint as his
own okay I have to roll it it's so bad
it wouldn't have mattered though because
jigsaw implemented a safe check by
sending an electric shock through Adam
to ensure that he's really dead which
obviously he isn't that's when the phone
that dr. Gordon found starts ringing and
it's his daughter Diana telling him that
the bad man from her room is holding
them hostage with a gun the captor also
puts Allison on the line and she tells
him not to believe Adams lies yeah let
me just make a note of that
so Gordon finds out the truth about Adam
that he's a private photographer hired
to follow dr. Gordon and gather photos
of what he's been doing after revealing
these photos Adam notices one that he
did not take an ass Gordon if somebody
else had been at the house Lawrence
determines that it's zapped the orderly
and upon putting a face to his
daughter's kidnapper he really does
break down into a fit of rage
time expires on the game and another
call comes in on the cell phone but this
time it's Alison he hears a struggle on
the phone and bursts into tears when he
hears gunfire and screaming on the other
end of the line he sobs on the bathroom
floor where he's electrocuted which may
have been jigsaw giving him one more
wake-up call to spring into action dr.
Gordon was at rock bottom and he had
reached his breaking points he goes
ballistic when the phone rings again and
he's unable to reject rolla's although
he looks crazy it's important to note
that this is what jigsaw would be
considered to be cure because Gordon was
being tested for his inability to feel
passion this could at least be
considered passion that's enough to
motivate him to cave into jigsaws
demands and cut off his own foot with
the hacks it would seem that even in
this emotional state Gordon did not lose
his intelligence and witty thinking he's
somehow able to communicate to Adam that
he wants to try the play dead trick one
more time
I'm guessing while we see the back of
his head right here he winks and then he
deliberately misses the gunshot this
ends up working to his advantage when
Zeb arrives at the bathroom to execute
him for failing to win the game before
time ran because Adam is able to get in
a surprise attack and disarms that
Gordon goes to get help and promises
Adam he'll come back to rescue he crawls
away with his one foot and cauterizes
the wound by burning it on a steaming
hot pipe but as he continues to hobble
away he loses too much blood and is on
the verge of passing out when he
encounters an unlikely save
dr. Lawrence Gordon had basically run
out of strength as he tried to navigate
his way out of the dark corridors beyond
the dilapidated bathrooms confines and
it ends up collapsing on the floor after
jigsaw revealed himself to Adam as the
man in the center of the bathroom game
he made his way out to find Lawrence who
had passed his tags he drags him to
safety and splashes some water on his
face while congratulating him on his
survival in the coming weeks he nursed
dr. Gordon until his wound had healed
and gave him the prosthetic foot when
his health returned to him he like
Amanda before him was grateful to jigsaw
for making him cherish his life once
more and came on as a disciple and
accomplice to jigsaw as worked over the
next couple of years at some point dr.
Gordon left the angel of Mercy Hospital
to go work at st. Eustace Hospital
I think this change may have been so he
could assist John with testing some of
his old co-workers at the angel of mercy
from a safe distance unlike some of his
other followers jigsaw saw great
potential in dr. Gordon and kept him a
secret from the other apostles Lawrence
became jigsaws go-to guy whenever one of
his traps or game's required some kind
of surgery or medical expertise one
example of this was in October of 2005
when he helped jigsaw set up the death
mask trap by using his surgical skills
to sew a key behind the victims right
eye which he would have to remove in
order to escape fans of saw to noticed
early on that the surgeon seen in the
video had a limp and theorized that it
could be dr. Gordon in April of 2006 he
assisted in the creation of the
mausoleum by sewing shut one man's eyes
and another man's mouth forcing them to
learn a better way to communicate in
order to avoid being pinched by this
powerful mechanism
not long after jigsaw was nearly on his
deathbed while putting together a game
that would test Amanda young and a
father named Jeff Gordon recommends that
John also include Jeff's wife Linda who
had worked under him when John was
diagnosed at angel of mercy
John would have Lynne performed the
brain surgery necessary for her to prove
her worth and keep John alive long
enough to see the end of Jeff's trial
after John passed away Gordon stayed in
the shadows as another jigsaw disciple
mark Hoffman carried on John's work
Lawrence demonstrates that he's still
devoted to John's teachings even after
John's death by leaving Hoffman a
warning when he starts to stray from
jigsaws ideals he leaves an anonymous
note reading I know who you are in order
to try to give Hoffman a hint that he
doesn't just have free rein to corrupt
jigsaws legacy warden would secretly
keep close
tabs and Hoffmann from there on out in
July of 2006 he received a parcel
through the mail slot in his door at the
hospital he opened it to find a
videotape with one final request from
John Kramer he wanted dr. Gordon to look
after his ex-wife Jill tuck watch over
Jill then should anything happen to her
in return for that I don't know what
secrets he thought he was going to learn
with jigsaw being dead but he's happy to
honor John's request anyways at some
point Gordon also starts attending the
support group for jigsaw survivor
I think he's mostly there to keep tabs
on the victims that he helps to
rehabilitate and make sure that they
don't relapse or anything because he
tends to sit in the chair outside the
perimeter of the group and seldom
participate himself that is until one
meeting in March of 2007 when a man
named Bobby dagen attends the group as
part of a press tour for his book
survive my story of overcoming jigsaw
dr. Gordon sees just one issue with this
publication he knows full well that
Bobby dagen was never one of the jigsaw
victims so he calls him out on it and
what is probably my favorite scene
involving dr. Gordon let's roll it
[Music]
markable if not a little perverse I'm
sure I speak for everyone here when I
say how grateful we are to be part of
your promotional
vd that's hilarious and I love how the
camera operator is just like oh we got
to get this and then everybody who
starts clapping that's remarkable but
Lawrence continues to keep a watchful
eye over Jill tuck and of course her
enemy mark Hoffman on March 12 2007
Hoffman is finally able to catch up with
an exact his revenge on Jill
which means Gordon is obligated to act
immediately Hoffman packs a bag of
supplies and sets fire to his savings
before setting out to make his escape
but he's met with three people in pig
masks were led by dr. Lawrence Gordon it
would seem that Gordon has taken a page
from his master and acquired a couple
disciples of his own he follows Jon's
instructions to leave Hoffman in the
location that means the most in the
place where he overcame jigsaws trial
the dilapidated bathroom but Hoffman is
not given the same option that he had
two-and-a-half years ago he pulls the
last remaining hacksaw out of Hoffman's
reach and throws it out of the room
leaving him to die and fulfilling his
teacher's final request
this would leave Gordon as the only
living true successor to jigsaw and
that's the exciting part about his
character in 2016 a forgotten disciple
from John Kramer's past a man named
Logan Nelson re-emerges and uses the
jigsaw name to get revenge on a cop that
had wronged him and many others while
this man was trained by Kramer at one
time he is strayed from his ideals in
the same way that Hoffman did at the
time of recording were yet to see how
dr. Gordon reacts to this but I imagine
based on everything that we know about
him that he's still keeping a watchful
eye and probably not too happy about
Logan Nelson causing his old master to
be dug up from his grave after having
his legacy altered in a negative way
like this so it'll be interesting to see
if dr. Gordon decides to intervene
John's intention from the very beginning
with dr. Gordon was to make him cherish
his life by reintroducing passion
originally that is intended to be
passion for his family Alison and Diana
it's never canonically shown what
happens to his wife and daughter but in
an audio commentary on saw 7 it stated
that they got divorced after Alison saw
how Lawrence had changed following the
bathroom game there's nothing in the
films to contradict that and it does
make sense because they aren't present
at the support group but we can't say
for sure until there's some evidence in
a future film
but what we can say is that passion was
reintroduced into Lawrence's life
anyways because he became passionate
about jigsaws teachings and helping
people improve their lives using his
methods this causes him to become the
only one of jigsaws apprentices to
become a true heir to John's vision of
what jigsaw could be and it'll be fun to
see how this new jigsaw continues with
the spirit of John's teachings going
forward let me know in the comments
though who else would you like to see
covered here on horror history I've
already got a playlist on the left of
the histories of other saw characters so
be sure to check those out and remember
to subscribe to seize these world for
new Horrors every week bring that DEATH
BATTLE for notifications and I'll see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive
you
[Music]